the retirement problem in the united
states and abroad is absolutely
atrocious simply so many people do not
have enough money to actually retire
when we look at the retirement savings
that people have around the world we
first have to look and say well what age
are people actually retiring and so
we've got a chart here that shows in the
united states the official retirement
age is 67 years old but the average
retirement age is actually 68 years old
we then look in the uk it's 65 as
official 64 and a half is the average if
we then go all the way down to japan 62
is the official retirement age but 69
almost 70 years old is the average
retirement age if we go ahead and we
look back in america at the percent of
americans who have no retirement savings
42 percent of 18 to 29 year olds have no
retirement savings they're young they
haven't started yet so they've got to
get started but if you go ahead and you
look at those over 60 years old one out
of every 10 americans have nothing saved
nothing not enough but nothing saved 1
out of 10. if you go ahead and you look
at 45 to 59 year olds almost one out of
every five americans 17 percent do not
have a single dollar saved for
retirement and then if you look from 30
to 44 one out of every four americans
has zero dollars saved for retirement
again it's not saying that they don't
have enough saved it's that they have
saved zero dollars obviously not very
good if we go ahead and we look at the
median retirement savings for americans
age 55 to 64 the numbers depending on
who you ask vary a little bit but it's
still not good if you asked the center
for retirement research in 2020 they
said that the median retirement savings
for americans between ages 55 to 64 is
120 000 across their 401k and ira if you
look at the median retirement savings by
age according to the transamerica center
for retirement services uh or studies
then you can see that that median
retirement savings is still very low
americans in their 60s 172 000 americans
in their 50s 117 000 if you go all the
way down to americans in their 20s it's
16 000
let's go to americans in the six in
their 60s 172 thousand dollars if you
simply were going to live on 45 000 a
year which for most people is much less
than in their working years 45 000 a
year means that if you retire at the age
of 62 you won't make it to your 70th
birthday without running out of money
that's how bad the situation is and so
most people do not have enough money
saved to actually retire they become
more and more dependent on social
security and other types of government
support
what we know though is that those
services already believe that they are
going to run out of money in the next 10
to 15 years and so if you're a young
person you unlikely to have very big
savings in your retirement you haven't
had a ton of time to make money spend
less than you make put some in your
retirement savings and then grow that
money but what we know is that the
wealthiest americans they have figured
it out you are financially incentivized
to put money in your retirement accounts
to grow that money and so that when you
do decide to stop working when you
decide to enjoy life and live and do
whatever you want you will have enough
money there to live for as long as you
possibly can you will not be worried
about money you will not be worried
about whether the government actually
has enough money in those social
services to pay you to live and so when
we look at the retirement accounts by
percentile of net worth what we can see
is this mean retirement account in
thousands
well
of course the bottom quartile they are
not doing very well you literally can't
see it on the chart if you then go and
you look at the top decile the 90 to 100
decile you can see that they have almost
a million dollars in retirement for
whatever comes their way and so
ultimately the gap between the 75th to
90th quartile uh or a percentile to the
90th to 100 is massive there's a
difference of between 200 000 or so and
almost a million dollars that is the
difference between those at the top and
everybody else but it is not something
where there's
game is rigged against you or there's
some sort of reason why you can't be in
the top percentile if you're a young
person the whole game the whole key to
this is to start early be aggressive and
continue to compound as much capital as
possible in those retirement accounts
you're incentivized to do it from a tax
perspective and so
rich people understand this better than
anybody the median net worth of
households with iras was nine times
higher than those that do not have one
so quite literally the people who have
an ira are nine times more likely to
make money than those without it rich
people understand that the tax
advantages of a retirement account are
there for everybody and so what are
those tax advantages and why are the
wealthy actually using this well there's
different types of tax advantages that
you can use there's different types of
iras the main two are a roth ira and a
traditional ira the traditional iras
allow you to contribute tax deduction
deductible assets so they lower your tax
burden today when you go ahead and you
contribute the government will not tax
you on the money that you're
contributing in to that traditional ira
a roth ira however allows you to make
contributions after you've paid your
taxes if you make a hundred dollars and
you pay 35 in taxes the remaining 65 you
may be able to take five dollars and put
it into the retirement you are not
getting any sort of tax break today but
you will not have to pay taxes when you
take the money plus gains out later so
one you get a tax deduction today and
you compound the money and have to pay
taxes when you withdraw the other you
pay your taxes today you take after tax
dollars you contribute it into a roth
ira and then you can compound that money
and when you take it out you pay no
taxes
i bet i know what you're thinking the
roth iras pretty damn cool and so in
both accounts you don't pay capital
gains tax if you trade within the
account you can go back and forth
between assets with no tax ramifications
and the maximum contribution for most
people is about six thousand dollars
annually and so ultimately what you want
to do is you want to max out that
concert that contribution whatever your
contribution maximum amount is you
should put that in every single year
whatever it takes get it in there and
then what you should be able to do is
think about what can you actually put
into your ira well your ira can hold all
sorts of different things especially
those roth iras you can do everything
from fire trucks and farmland also
private company equity we've talked
about people like peter thiel in the
past but you can also put bitcoin and
for most young people they do not know
this you can actually put tax advantage
dollars into a retirement account and
then you can purchase bitcoin within the
retirement account you can hold it for
very long periods of time and if you use
after tax dollars so after i pay my
taxes this year if i take some dollars
that i have left over i put it into my
roth ira i then purchase bitcoin in the
roth ira and i hold it for the next 30
years when i take it out i will not have
to pay taxes on the gains very very tax
efficient way to gain bitcoin exposure
and so when you think about this there's
a whole bunch of different ways that you
can do it i can tell you what i
personally do i use something called
choice and i've talked to these guys a
million times over there they do
everything from literally farmland and
fire trucks to allowing people to do it
with bitcoin the reason why i use choice
is because they allow you not only to
buy the bitcoin and have it held by a
custodian but also if you want you can
hold the private keys of the bitcoin in
your retirement account and so they have
all kinds of different options i highly
suggest if you do not have a roth ira
you should go and you should do it i
literally emailed the guys and i said
hey how the hell can you guys help
people do this and these are the three
bullet points they sent back they allow
you to hold bitcoin and other assets in
a retirement account alongside stocks
ets fire trucks farmland anything else
there's no annual fee and the only fees
you pay are when you trade about one
percent and earlier this month they
launched a referral program that pays
you and your friends to get your money
out of the legacy system in bitcoin i
don't know how the referral program
works i feel like if i'm talking about
them right now we should be getting a
referral but we're not so maybe we will
have to try to figure that out later so
the whole key to this is if you go and
you open a roth ira pay your taxes take
after tax dollars invest it in a roth
then you can buy bitcoin or other assets
you don't have to buy bitcoin you can
buy stocks or anything else and then
basically you hold those assets for long
periods of time all of the compounding
and capital gains that you get when you
take it out you won't have to pay taxes
which is like one of the greatest
arbitrages in the world in terms of
being able to actually invest and use
the tax code to your advantage